you like
am i doing a good job too too
do you have money to pay no
no i just want to be free on the house
it's a spa day at the thompson house
am i doing a good job too too tristan
thompson shared a video showing him
painting his three-year-old daughter
true's nails
you like am i doing a good job to too
you have money to pay no
no i just want to be free on the house
in the cute clip the father-daughter duo
are sitting on the floor
as the nba player gives his baby girl a
manny
true picked at the color pink for her
nails and it seems that tot was thrilled
she was getting this five-star service
for free
you have money to pay no
no i just want to be free on the house
alongside the video tristan added heart
emojis and wrote
gotta keep my baby girl right am i doing
a good job too too
of course tristan shares 2-2 with his
ex-chloe kardashian
the former couple split in june after
new allegations
surfaced against the 30 year old nba pro
who was the subject of similar scandals
in the past
you know tristan and i definitely are
not perfect do you trust him
i mean i definitely trust him as a
friend and all those
things i can't worry too much about
everything else i know the growth and
all the work that he's done i know
all the help that he's got and the
constant efforts that he makes every
single day
at the time a source told e.t they
ultimately decided to end the
relationship for chloe's mental health
and the pair is done romantically after
chloe gave tristan several chances
and i'm just super happy and content and
i'm focused on
work and like taking care of me my body
and soul and
true but the two left on good terms and
the breakup was not dramatic
i don't think there needs to be
negativity on anywhere i think it's just
a story that's being told but anybody
picking a side
or you know condemning any human i think
this is a part of life as for chloe's
famous family
they have her back i mean i feel like
yeah hey
in fact a source recently told et that
the 36 year old reality star's fam
thinks her split from tristan is good
and healthy for her
it is what it is so what's next well
tristan and chloe are now focused on
co-parenting their three-year-old
daughter true
after all the source says chloe just
wants her baby girl to have a good
relationship
with her father
you like am i doing a good job to too
you have money to pay no
no i just want to be free on the house